it's the 10th anniversary of the last of
us this year and naughty dog is bringing
the hype with game director Neil
drockman Coming Out Swinging stating The
Last of Us multiplayer will be the
Studio's most ambitious project to date
speaking to comic book jokman said
naughty dog has been working on the
title for a long time specifying that
work began on the project before The
Last of Us Part 2 was released in 2020
The Last of Us Part 2 was originally
expected to launch with a new version of
the first games factions multiplayer
mode Naughty Dog explained in 2019 that
the scope of the factions mode of the
studio originally announced for the game
grew to the point where it couldn't be
included alongside the main campaign the
new Last of Us multiplayer game hasn't
been officially unveiled yet though
naughty dog has released concept art and
other details in 2023 naughty dog will
begin to provide details on the game
which the studio said is quote shaping
up to be a fresh new experience from our
studio Norwich dog is known best for its
single player story games and the studio
stressed that the new Last of Us
multiplayer title will be rooted in the
company's quote passion for delivering
incredible stories characters and
gameplay another multiplayer game with
some huge expectations is arcanes read
for while Arcane Leon was the studio
behind gamespot's 2021 game of the year
when a death Loop it'll be the developer
behind 2017's prey Arcane Austin that is
helming the vampire hunting Cooperative
shooter while more details in the title
will be coming in January 25th's Xbox
developer direct some information about
it might have already leaked namely its
release date according to Industry
Insider extasis who has previously
accurately revealed details on hideo
kojima's overdose the release date will
be May 2nd of this year quote if there
were any doubt redfall can now be 100
confirmed with the release date of May
2nd 2023 ecstasis tweeted after fellow
Insider Brad Sams posted a pair of
cryptic hinting at arcane's upcoming
game the tweets from Sams have since
been deleted but they contained emoji
that read quote redfall 2nd May before
they were removed we likely won't have
to wait long for official word for
Microsoft as red 4 will be headlining
the developer Direct on the 25th with
Xbox confirming that the event will
cover both single and multiplayer combat
customization and bosses for the first
person shooter another highly
anticipated release this year is
Assassin's Creed Mirage a smaller
experience in the franchise that is more
akin to the earlier releases in the
series than the recent absolutely
gargantuan RPG focused ones in an
interview with Games Radar the game's
creative director Stephanie budo expands
on what that means budon states that the
studio has heard fans desires for a
character-driven story and that the game
will focus on what the team considers to
be the core pillars of the franchise
stabbing sneaking and running while
Baghdad the sole location in the game
will be much smaller than the maps of
the more recent entries like Odyssey and
Valhalla the new technology used in
those games will be implemented to be a
much more densely populated accurate
simulation of a city of that scope than
any of the earlier Assassin's Creeds
ever had this apparently has led to
massive improvements over one of the
series most iconic gameplay elements
blending into crowds however rather than
needing to find specific clusters of
civilians to hide amongst according to
budong any pocket of three civilians
will provide that opportunity are we
about to get the best Assassin's Creed
ever let us know in the chat if that
sounds like your bag and we'll see you
here for more Gamespot news
[Music]
foreign